hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast stabilization of native
and functional membrane proteins for
drug discovery presented by an astro
Harry chief scientific officer of calyx
R we are excited to bring you this
educational webcast presented by lab
roots and sponsored by get Co part of
thermo Fisher Scientific before we begin
I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem please join me now in
welcoming dr. Ann - jahari I will now
turn the presentation over to him okay
thank you very much Christine and thank
you all for organizing this webinar I
don't know if you can hear me correctly
but okay perfect thank you to all the
people that are attending this webinar
so what I would like to do today is to
try to tell you what we do at Ericsson
and then to try to explain basically how
we stabilize native and actual membrane
proteins for drug discovery so this
presentation is is already organized
that I will be describing some case
studies and then hopefully I'll be happy
also to address some of your questions
if you have some at the end of the
presentation since it was said said
previously it's an interactive
discussions and happy to
dress specific questions so before I go
to the scientific part this is a few
words about character so it's a
biotechnology company based in France we
have two sides one side in late Indian
in France and where we do all the
biochemistry part and I will describe
exactly what we do precisely and then
the other side which is based in Avenue
across cooperation we have good
University Avenue where we actually do
chemistry we basically sanitize
compounds that have an important
stabilization and also lubrication
effect and those compounds are of Aveda
Quakers I don't have time to go into
detail but really these are key
chemistry that we develop to be able to
actually stabilize membrane proteins and
use them for drug discovery applications
okay so this is just you know slide tell
you that yes it is in front but we also
have offices in the US and in Japan now
the reason we are really focusing
membrane proteins and this is quite
obvious but it's always good to remind
people in the audience it has memory
coding some really key proteins for drug
discovery for medical relevance but me
by saying this it's important to realize
also that these proteins are extremely
challenging and that's reason why you
don't have much of crystal structure
salt don't have much of drugs developed
against these proteins were on similes
for example you blow against these
proteins because it's just simply
difficult to produce them and have them
stable in solution so that's reason why
we decided to really to come up with
ideas and then generate tools to be able
to solubilize them stabilize them and I
will tell you little bit more about this
in the next couple of slides okay so at
character what we do is trying to start
from different particle membrane so
different biological material and the
goal is to maintain functionality when
you solve a line and sterilize
approaching the goal is to keep the
protein native and this is important
because there are all kind of approaches
that can consist on mutating the
proteins also adding brilliant proteins
in order to stabilize them ok that's
what while this is quite nice but my to
a certain extent for some specific cases
a little bit far from the negative
situation and therefore ended up
generating drugs or three bodies or or
small molecule compounds against
something that actually it's slightly or
very different from the native situation
that was recently decided to avoid
modifying the protein but instead of
modifying the protein will rather decide
to modify the chemistry around the
protein so that's why we are innovating
in thermo chemistry of civilization and
our stabilization now just a small
summary like our activities we have
different activities related to
discovery this is what we call the
organization for example or a
notification or localization sometime
also crystallization so this is all
related to membrane proteins and we can
discuss this in more detail later on but
typically the main focus is also to
produce proteins for drug discovery so
how to relax we are you have to be able
to express the protein as well as
possible as good as possible and so we
the reason and present in also today is
because we start looking to that more
carefully and also collaborate with the
best people and I take them official
term official scientist in scientific is
also one of the best in term of
innovation of expression and that's also
aspect to be able to generate it
cells that express the protein and
they'll be able to have a starting
material that is a decent starting
material to be able to extract it purify
it stabilize it and then go to different
applications and crystallization but not
only procedure so during this process
what is really important is to verify
that the protein is not unfolded that
the protein is still functional I think
that's really key and because if you use
SDS or use some classical occasion some
time you can solubilize your protein but
you don't know actually what you are
salafi nice nice organizing most of the
time aggregate and you don't want to
generate hate soldiers made drugs
against aggregate so it's important
really to to qualify material you will
be using for drug discovery so that's
really trying to quality quality control
these samples and I will come back to
this now how do we do that practically
so we have developed an Nam demonstrated
process which is basically a detergent
surfactant based approach so this was
patented six patents actually now the
idea is to avoid refolding
avoid meta changes avoid truncation
avoid fusion and still have an
improvement in stability of the main
proteins and still maintain
functionality and structural Integrity's
and I think that's really the key is to
aspect
structure integrity and then the
functionality these are the two
important parameters that you have to
include into your equation into your
solemnization verification equation if
you want to end up with decent sample to
be used for drug discovery now how do we
do that I told you already that we
instead of mutating the protein we
actually decided to change chemistry
around the protein so there are
different compounds that we developed
basically four categories today we'll be
focusing mainly and one of the
categories here in gold so the compound
helped solubilize and stabilized at the
same time I think that's
the key because this is where things can
go wrong when you don't stabilize at
this step because you can solubilize and
then if you sort of realize the protein
and the protein is unfolded it's really
difficult and to stabilize it further
because you already enfold it from the
beginning so that's why from the
beginning you have to combine it to
aspect solubilize and sterilize then
there are also other compounds that help
to stabilize protein that is already
quite well fold
can can hear me okay yes I was saying
that basically we can be using detergent
micelles protein liposomes membrane
scaffold protein or labor particles so
basically the idea is really to sort of
realize you know in the best scenario
and then you can formulate in different
platforms if you wish to be used for
your application so these are true
applications that describe basically
some the first ones review we describe
different format that exists and the
second one it's actually a scientific
article describing how the possibility
to actually quantify the detergent
around the protein to be actually used
for modeling or to be used to learn more
about Carly and maps right now this is a
case study would be describing its
classical gbzr it's actually really well
very well characterized community except
that the one that everybody is actually
working with is a truncated and mediated
version of this so our challenge was to
to decide to actually work with a native
form of the protein that's mean without
sedation so it's around locating and
there are eight mutations in this
protein in the literature and so the
first question was are we able to
express it in this case we could express
in this particular also expression and
sex cells so I don't go into the detail
but this is a really classical
expression I would say I'm sure that
using a sophisticated expression system
from thermo Fisher will give us more
chances to have more protein and maybe
more healthy protein but we're not try
this yet but maybe this is something
that we'll be doing in collaboration of
weeks
so now when you express the protein what
you want to do is to look for the right
occasion condition to extract it so we
noticed that most of the time it aren't
a tendency to come back again to the
same detergent condition that they used
to have and I think that's really I
quote somehow and especially when you
think about the diversity of membrane
proteins and also the diversity of the
version that goes with is not really
there so it's a it's not really
correlated so that reason we think it's
important the screen wash using new
tools that we have recently larger
screen 96 conditions including some of
priori compounds of carissa but also
commercially available detergents and
then also combination because this is
also an important parameter the often we
stick to one compound or one iteration
and combining them can also be extremely
valuable and need to be tested and I
think in our hand at least we could see
that is an added value in combining
tools now we could find the conditions
that allowed to summarize a protein here
we're not going to detail but basically
we could mobilize total protein that you
see in the Western blots here in the
right side of this presentation and then
we could then use terror affinity I
believe in this case it's like to purify
the protein now the question is okay you
could clarify it could express your
protein you could purified how does it
look like in term of what I mentioned
before 10 or 20 controls in terms of
behavior and solution also in general
functionality so in term of
functionality the only functional assay
that we have done here is actually two
already like in binding using well
characterized ligand which is this CDM
24:38 I ok and she's actually an agonist
we have looked into a key reason to all
kind of study to verify this
able to mind all I can hear is only one
point that we got to show showing the
specificity of the binding of the ligand
when he compared the glue which is the
total to the green which is basically
specific by really come up to the
conclusion that the protein is healthy
enough to be able actually to bind to
the ligand
now if you look into a native page you
see that the protein goes into the gel
and that means that you don't have
advocates and the proteins seem to be
quite homogeneous interestingly in size
exclusion chromatography also see
similar conclusion which is that the
protein does not come out into the void
volume it seems to behave as sample so
okay so this looks nice and next
question is is it still is it stable so
how do you look into stability we have
looked in here at that by size exclusion
chromatography and we could see that
over time after even seven days this
native gbzr is actually still stable
even at 37 degree this is quite stable
after seven days we he you could see
some shoulder here the beginning of
three days but does not seem to be a
worse actor four more days so obviously
we have quite stable which sounds quite
easy but actually it's quite astonishing
because adenosine receptor like all
native GPCRs is not and people have been
truncated and mutating it and I can to
be able to stabilize and here it does
not seem to be a problem when you find
the right chemistry that stabilize the
protein now when you look into another
readout in term of stability which is
described here here is a method that was
published two years ago that consistent
heating the sample sunshi fusion it and
then performing western blot and then
looking into the intensity of the band
at T zero and then over time and then
you see here that's in red
the red experiment with the we could
come up with the TN which is around 45
degrees which is very well consistent
with the literature okay and then the
green is actually the conditions that
you could come up with which is a
combination between DD n hour you could
see that you have significant
improvement in term of thermal stability
without having to rotate any single
amino acid and I think this is really
for me an illustration and we have of
course seen that for all kind of sorry
target that we wrote which of course
these presentations focus only on the
data that we can communicate on that our
outcome of our organization development
of course all the data we are generating
with caramel companies network with this
is of course not is closed here but you
see it's quite similar conclusions
similar tools we'll be using the
application so we also looked into this
sample by the come across copy this was
a collaboration University we could see
different particles crowded particles of
course but this is also an indication
that the protein is not aggregated as
was illustrated by now recently we
initiated also collaboration with
another group this time where we are now
able to look at two different fragments
and see how those fragments can bind or
not to our GPCR energy GPR and the idea
is first I don't show it here but we
could already show that you know you
know zine is able to bind to a receptor
caffeine is also to mine and then
interestingly could now learn about
mechanistically if two ligands can bind
both to the same receptor or is able to
compete one on the other and this really
more and more developed to understand
they can stick
alter history can allosteric binding of
different fragment that we want now to
discover so this was done by this TV and
also here by waterlog C so it's without
going to the details but typically the
idea is if you have high quality protein
in solution you might want you to do fpd
D using NMR for example or using SPR so
of course if the two methods can be
applied so you can mobilize using your
tagged your type into your screen
okay now this is another protein which
is transporter so this is a public to
work you can have a look to that I think
will summarize it's only in one slide so
the idea is to to produce this protein
in the optimal condition that was
described in literature time of
civilization and and then one other
experiment will be to produce this
protein using one of the in this case
was a calyx ionized protein and
untwisting nearly see here in these
histograms is that this transporter is
absolutely not active in the
state-of-the-art condition so basically
using so in comparison to the membrane
we could maintain 90% of the ATPase
activity of this transporter using our
clearly we could was probably one of the
initial example on term of how we could
maintain functional stages of the
protein so so we can have a look to this
article to typically even if you have a
pure a nice protein does not tell you
that it's going to be active and
obviously active or not
this is now another so I really did the
idea behind this presentation is to
illustrate basically the approach we are
using starting from different cell types
and then being able to to illustrate
that this approach can apply to
different family of membrane proteins
but also to different cell types for
also different applications so here it's
the case of protein that will Express in
HEK cells sorry I forget to mention this
was from equal I what I showed you
before was a CF 9 and now this was from
heck cells and the idea was are we able
or not to extract let's say the natives
complex of these two proteins fast and
then EGF receptor and are we maintaining
to certain extent or atomic state and
indeed we do native page you see that
you have high molecular weight protein
that's correspond to the traumatic form
or the dynamic form for fast and energy
receptor respectively should that mean
that the way you take the protein out of
the membrane is somehow maintain the
right electronic state I'm not talking
about confirmation because that's
another story but at least in term of
assembly you actually and I will show
you at the end in this presentation how
we could actually maintain protein
protein interactions and actually
identify and know the partner of one
tracing coating now this I will not go
into detail because this is not
published work yet so this was a
collaboration we had with scripts and
IRB on HIV envelope protein which is
made up of gp120 and gp41 is actually a
trimer
of protein that was not stable at all
and the best conditions that our
partners could find is basically what's
shown here after three hours the trauma
is falling apart so using some of our
campus reaction could actually stabilize
this envelope protein and we could show
that it's a functional complex that we
are able to extract and not some kind of
artists
actual extermination ethic so please
have a look in the next couple of months
on the literature if you want to learn
more about this piece is not published
but it will hopefully be published so I
don't have time to go into so I will
move on now to another family of protein
which is an ion channel so in this case
it's a cool transporter it's a potassium
chloride cotransporter that we worked
with this is an important channel
because it's involved in control of most
races and it's also in water loops of
course difference in result from the
biochemical particular nothing released
except that it's might probably made of
twelve transmembrane domain and its
might existence or little man
okay so we have expressed its protein
egg cells and then we could solubilize
it you see here is their line three in
the left gel this is the soluble
fraction component in the total you
could purify it also by affinity and now
by using cross-linking using [ __ ] i
could show that the protein can exist as
a dimer and can probably also exist as a
monomer so this was really nice
illustration that the protein does not
exist tetra marrow octoman or whatever
complex humor it seems to exist as a
true populations monomers and diverse
and I'm twisting me the divers at the
interface of the diameter could see that
in presence of ATP we actually lose the
dimer so which suggests at the interface
of the demonization
we have these approaches so again this
is another story that's about to be
published I don't have time to go into
the detail but typically what we could
do and this is a collaboration with a
pharma company we could actually solve
the structure by electronic cross copy
of this protein and then do mass
spectrometry to learn more about what
our residuals involved
cutie what are the postulations
glycosylation that are involved and this
is a story that will be submitted
actually and next week so here I think
what the take-home message from this
slide is just yes we indeed we can use
we have the right cell expression system
this to be discussed we can solubilize
the right polymeric state and they're
characterized by different goals so by
you could also do by coronal et cetera
to immobilize this channel and then you
look for binding of specific on type
honest so the applications are quite
values variable it can be structural
biology or like in screening or mass
spectrometry and characterization so but
the key is do you express or not the
protein correctly and I think that's
that's an important point to keep in
mind especially for this discussion
now another channel also and I'll try to
accelerate a bit the presentation that
we have time for discussions and
exchange what's really important is to
show that this is another channel which
is in this case a proton selective ion
channel from the influenza as we have
been using as a case study to show that
we are able to produce the full an
explosion in education that was not
produced actually until now because
people have been sensitized and only
peptide that is responsible for the
conductivity for the poor as you can see
here was several papers describing a
structure of this high-impact papers
describing the structure of this but
nobody really could express and
cellulite and purify the coolant version
of this channel and that was basically
our channel challenge so we use the
virus itself to infect cells that are
MDC K cells then we looked into the poly
membrane 7 start looking to see if we
have the right
until Jessica's were expressed an
interest in me yes we could see no I
mean days we could see in my glutenin we
could see and - then we started a
solubilizing the protein as you can see
here that's a soluble fraction and
that's the pellet so in the pellet there
is nothing and in the solubilized
fraction you have pretty much everything
- so we could serve as totally protein
now the question is are you able to
purify it and indeed we could purify it
we could also see in gel cultivation
that it was not aggregated but then we
did not really know what's the organic
state so when you do this page you could
start saying well I have an oligomer but
I'm not in a position to tell we know
from there from the literature that the
functional stage of this channel is
actually a tetramer
but we have to show that it exists as a
drummer and that's exactly what we have
done here using cross-linking using
literally you could go from one of our
og drummer so obviously what we
expressed solubilize and purify was a
tetrameric version of the protein so we
know that we know that this is the
atomic version is somehow the functional
state of the protein okay but so that
suggests that we could insulate the
functional protein but this is only a
suggestion so it's some kind of and
direct evidence so that's why we had to
come up with an assay to actually
measure the activity that's what we have
done here we used a purified protein
inserted into lipid bilayer start
measuring current and depends pH because
it's protons Japan Channel and we could
see a specific current voltage
measurements here curves and this is
typically an indication that the protein
was functional we want further by adding
a specific inhibitor which is demented
in then we could go from totally active
to totally inactive so that mean that
the way we summarize and purify the
protein could allow to maintain the
functionality and the ultimate state of
the which is exactly what we expect for
all
I want to add also to this and to stress
the hack that's here I'm talking about
publish data or R&D work but is this
actually the same work we are doing with
highly druggable targets like naps or 2x
campout sorry proteins that are involved
in really different paths illusion that
are extremely credible targets okay so
last couple of slides to tell you that
we could also stabilize without having
trouble eyes so this is an example of a
model protein that everybody's familiar
with which is bacteriorhodopsin the
doctor and obscene was surveyed eyes
purified by I don't remember what
company and that we basically just
bought but then asked the question
what's happen if you do suspend this in
presence of different compounds and how
these compounds can unpack positively or
negatively on the stability or the
function stability of this target and
that's what we see using all J proteins
absolutely not stable when you look into
the Furious solid to the absorbance 160
as an indication now using
is it back seem to be back but I'm not
sure good okay so I keep going
so obviously what this what I like is in
this slide is the fact that it shows you
that you don't need to mutate the
protein you only have to play around
with the right chemistry that stabilizes
a protein so here it's actually the same
protein and you have cases which
absolutely not favorable for the
stability or the functional stability of
the protein and all those using this
calyx glycoside you really have and it's
gonna be the same story with other
targets now similarly we know that
cholesterol hallucinates have been
developed by several people missus and
used heavily GPCR community to stabilize
membrane proteins we thought okay why
don't we use the some kind of static
compounds that we link to one of the
collection that form and see might have
some stimulation effect and that's
exactly what we have done and this is
actually a pattern that is where we
could show that this compound have a
significant improvement in term of
ligand binding study on gpcrs so here
it's don't remember what GPC have used
but we have tried in different GPCRs and
we see not only stabilize the protein
and in the top of that we actually
stabilizing ligand binding properties of
the receptor and just to finish the
presentation I'm happy to take questions
this is an example where we basically
used the same approach but not address
the same question so here the question
is was a goal in collaboration with
group in Italy so the the idea was that
these collaborators had focused on a
protein called back tree which is
pancreatic cancer marker
it's actually macrophage to a specific
and no receptor the question is they
always see this protein around
macrophage by fluorescence but they had
no idea why this presentation this or
this protein is actually linked to this
membrane so the idea or the hypothesis
was that if we see it it's most probably
because it's binding to a receptor to a
specific partner okay so if you use a
native colonization method as I
described before you might be able to
actually maintain protein protein
interactions and therefore if you use a
pulldown are say you can enrich your
native factory receptor complexes and
then maybe using mass spectrometry you
can actually notify the partner and
that's exactly what we have done and
this is how we could identify and return
and just trust membrane protein to as a
specific receptor back tree in
macrophage and this was crossed
validates by different methods I don't
have time to discuss today but typically
this was published in intercom years ago
so the he sees the same approach can
actually apply address different kind of
questions so produce protein to be used
for drug discovery including structure
based on discovery fragment paste drug
design but also a g-body discovery and
vaccine and in the other time we can
actually use the same approach to
identify new partners and also to be
organized I did not talk about this but
if you have a specific ligand that's
binding to specific receptor you can
actually learn which one is binding to
which one so and this worked four or
five years and we have been working on
more than 140 different targets and of
course most of them Tim proportion I
would say the IGBT our scientists are
the most important ones of course there
are other ones transporters receptors
also violent targets and difference
scientific partners that we have so
different ones I'm talking about so
chemistry - stabilization is a new
consortium we could come up with
recently to generate new surfactant -
and also polymers to stabilize
solubilize and sterilize membrane
proteins and then other academy groups
all over the world I mentioned already
and then recently and first interactions
we initiated together with Telmo Fisher
Scientific and this is hopefully really
bridging the gap between expression
world and then drug discovery and we are
happy to be part of this discussion and
thank you very much for your time I'm
happy to take questions that you have
some great thank you so much dr. Joe
herring for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button we'll answer as many of
your questions as we have time for so
let's get started our first question is
how different is your approach to others
so I do not I do not hear your questions
if you have any questions it was get
some how
no problem I asked how different is your
approach to others yeah I think the if I
try to I think I guess this presentation
is helpful to understand this typically
I think the approach that we are using
is an alternative approach which is to
what people most of time are using which
consists on stabilizing membrane
proteins by Amita Genesis by sonication
and also by fusion proteins so the idea
here is really to mutate the chemistry
around the protein and find the right
Pinetree fine-tune the conditions that
help to survive and stabilize membrane
proteins and keeping the right native
sequence to be to hopefully don't
interfere too much with structural and
kinetic energies of the protein of
course is not always a guarantee that's
using a specific iteration surfactant
you are not able to change a little bit
a confirmation or or totally the
confirmation this is something that you
have to address but I think it's not one
approach against the other I think it's
just a complimentary approach that help
to diversity projects from the beginning
and I think that's really a key point to
keep in mind when you start and drug
discovery program
thank you for our next question we have
is mammalian cell suitable for the
membrane protein expression and do you
ever successfully purify a membrane
protein from a memo from mammalian cells
yeah I think mammalian sorry
mammalian cells are great for two
reasons one of the reasons I think is
that you are able to scale up the
production easily and the second I think
it's related to the quality of the
protein or to relative to the cost
structure and modifications especially
when we work with the human proteins
it's always good to keep in mind that
you want to have some post rush and
modifications of caustic rod probably
not be exactly the same ones that you
are that you are that you want for your
protein actually often you don't know
exactly what's pgms you want but it's
important to keep in mind that to
organism that you want for which you
want to express the protein of interest
that's why mammalian cells are suitable
and I think that's will be more and more
useful for poor membrane protein
production toward through this Korean
yes indeed we have been using that for
larger production of proteins for drug
discovery
thank you okay next question how do I
know which compound to buy in order to
stabilize and syllable eyes my membrane
protein do you sell kits and if so do I
need specific detection methods or
simply native gel and sec to determine
which is the best compound hey that's a
good question it's a very good question
it's it all I think there is not always
you know the same answer to all
questions so it's always depend what
question you want to address one
application what target what quality
control you want to implement that are
correlated to this application into
these goals and so this is a que always
a case by case scenario there is no
recipe for success or a recipe is to to
adapt basically the the protocols and
and the quality controls that you want
to implement we actually saw use prior
trick and parents but we also use
classical detergents that are available
commercially available so and also
combine them I think I mentioned this in
the presentation combine them to be able
to address specific questions in term of
stability in term of civilization
so our compounds are not available and
you cannot find them if you want to test
basically process we are using we have
to contact us and we can put together a
program to study particular we don't
sell them because what we sell is
basically membrane protein by chemistry
and not on chemistry so there are people
that are selling detergents as a kid we
think that this is not helpful what we
are given access to is actually
expertise on membrane
but we are happy to discuss this later
on please contact me and then we can
talk about this aspect in the email
address actually indicated here if you
want to contact me
okay thank you for the next question is
your approach to apply to a specific
membrane protein family or different
ones it's what I tried to illustrate in
this presentation is the fact that we
can apply this approach to a wide range
of families not only to class one gbzr
for example so it it's not specifically
applied for one subtype of proteins it
can apply to first different families of
membrane proteins I mentioned GPCRs I
mentioned our insurance I mentioned a
viral target I mentioned transporters so
they are extremely different from the
bike and we can contribute and still we
are using a similar tools to actually
address that and you can also use this
approach to apply to apply supposition
established methodology starting from
different particle materials
so I mentioned virus I mentioned hex
else I mentioned CH also as I mentioned
bacteria imagine yeast so yeah so it's
quite diverse the only thing that they
are in common is actually membranes
that's it
okay next question how do you stabilize
membrane proteins really the idea step a
little bit back on the way we work
proteins not systematically be scary
because my protein is not stable in
solution and right away start
engineering it I think it's important to
fine tune the conditions in term or use
the right detergent and this can be also
through the use of classical invasion
not on you noticed were not history by
interaction with all kind of membrane
protein experts all over the world it's
very often they come back to the same
equations because they were successful
using one or two details and if you
think about the diversity of membrane
proteins do you think about the
diversity of detergents people are using
does not really fit so you would have to
be open mind and then screen different
Asian conditions and then have a clear
view what are the quality controls you
want to implement and then I think it's
going to be successful so that the way
we stabilize actually just by changing
the chemistry around by adapting I
cancel on the protein to a specific
target but also to a specific
application because think about it you
want to crystallize the protein you
don't put a fire coat in the same way
and if you want to use it to generate
hits or to do by by a core like in
screening or to do
I don't know antibody discovery so these
are completely different applications
that's why the solid Asian purification
meteorology have to actually adapt this
and include this last format or the last
preparation into the equation to be able
to be successful
thank you okay next question how do you
qualify your Salou belies or purified
proteins in terms of function and
structure evaluating if this is an
aggregate or not for example or that we
do size exclusion chromatography we also
do an 80-page cross-linking sometimes or
so dynamic light scattering ITC so
basically the question is how that my
protein behave in solution and what we
don't want is to have aggregate that's
obvious and what you also want is to
have a homogeneous protein so therefore
dimeric form and tetrameric form if you
have a mixture populations or not so
that's for the behavior in solution for
sure using eight electrons copy to see
how does it look like will provide
protein can also help to gain insight
into if my protein is genius
so that's for the structural aspect in
term of functionality this is always
protein dependents or family dependent
so classically for GPC art or to be doin
is like environment studies we will do
my core will be doing
Harrison spine if you have a feel for if
you have antibodies that recognize the
target we can actually use this to do
Eliza for iron channels what we've been
doing is like environmentally so
typically you can mark a toxin and see
the toxins in the turbine
also do electrophysiology or say similar
to chocolate when I was showing you so
basically can insert a protein lipid
bilayer and start measuring current so
this is not always straightforward
because you have to find really the
right conditions to insert your protein
and then you have a specific signal and
the only way to really ensure that this
specific signal is related to your
protein is in specific inhibitors that
will shut down the channel specifically
that's one way mo transporters you can
actually measure you can reconstitute
your protein protein I don't for example
start measuring currents so so that's
okay always a case by case scenario from
the structure point of view you can use
the same tools for all familiar proteins
but then from the from the functional
point of view you can adapt the quality
controls depending on the biochemistry
or the functionality of the target
specific functionality of the target
thank you
if there are no more questions I would
like to once again thank dr. Joe Harry
for his presentation I would also like
to thank lab rates and give Co part a
Thermo Fisher Scientific for making
today's educational webcast possible
additional questions will be answered
and published on Thermo Fisher
Scientific sweb site you will receive an
email notification when answers are
available and before we go I'd like to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through April of 2018 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's light of it that's all for now
and thank you so much for joining us we
hope to see you again soon goodbye